bonsoir monsieur dutil bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous spécialement de paris
ce soir pour parler un peu de cette
transaction il ya trois ans on avait
annoncé l'acquisition d'une part
majoritaire d'un fonds américain dans
can am
expliquez-nous ce qui motive votre
décision aujourd'hui
d'abord à 2017 les transactions qu'on a
fait avec un ip c'était pour la
privatisation de canal on était dans un
creux le si vous souvenez l'action de
canam était à 6 2 lors de six de leurs
vins on a fait une transaction à 12h30
qu'on a payé une prime presque 200% qui
était la valeur aux livres c'est quelque
chose que je tenais pour nos
actionnaires et dans une entreprise
comme canam qui est dans un métier
cycliques être publiques c'est à chaque
5,6 à l'os et il ya calvaire l'autre
montrent plus pendant 50 ans puis d'un
coup de marché baissent de 15 20 30 %
puis le titan bas perte des plus fous tu
recommences au bout de 5 si l'accord se
fait je pense que sincèrement 84 cas
qu'on est allé public dans une compagnie
cycle et c'était une erreur
ouais et donc c'était une erreur d'aller
en bourse
c'est ça c'est un dada zune métiers
cycliques plus tôt je crois très
sincèrement que dans un marché où qui
demande la croissance qui demandent du
rama et que tu est cyclique et or aucun
contrôle
dans notre métier à nous des années j'ai
vu des émissions de 50 pour ça ça fait
que à 50 % de diminution il ya d'autres
choses qui touchent moins de volumes et
les marges qu en fait compte 10 pareil
ça fait que c'était difficile
c'était important pour vous en 2010 est
d'arrêter sa de sortir du marché
boursier ça passait par un fonds
américain
et aujourd'hui vous sentez que c'est
possible de revenir de racheter de
redonner propriété québécoise
majoritaire à can am par contre il ya
une chose qu'il faut c'est qu'un fonds
américain à tshwane le matin qui font un
achat la chose qui prime pour les autres
c'est de sortir à profit qui dans les
délais les plus courts possibles
normalement à saisir sur 4 5 1 on a été
capable afin de les convaincre
après 30 mois mais pas quand on ramène
elle contrôle au québec on arabe d'une
chose qui est très importante pour moi
on est de la beauce on a une usine qui a
800 employés à saint gédéon de beauce
200 à saint-georges ça fait mille
personnes dans beauce que tout est
contrôlé par des amis que new york
chicago ou peu importe quand tu arrives
dans un boutique la première place que
tu va occuper les emplois plutôt que
c'est un les unit le plus loin tout de
même cédé une performance avec une mais
deux exceptionnels ces nouveaux seront
qui paieraient de prix ça fait que rue
je pense que j'ai travaillé j'ai
travaillé avec les grands pères hl2d
gauck sodano douzaine que les femmes
soient dans une usine aujourd'hui à mon
argent la première chose qui est
importante d'abord c'était d'avoir des
bons partenaires puis de les convaincre
qu'on faisait une bonne transaction au
bon prix puis après sur mes quatre
enfants forex ou est d'accord que l dans
une coupe donner leurs calculs plus
rapide aux deux autres que moi être ben
que qui acceptent parfaite quand ils
vont voir un challenge parce que on
s'est acheté de l'ouvragé l'on sait pour
on prend pas de retraite mais je vous
écoute si vous parlez
la famille puis vous parler des grands
parents et des parents de vos employés
mais vous même quand on parle de la
création de canam en 1960 puis vous en
66 avec manach et la suite des choses
finalement c'est une longue histoire
familiale
vous teniez aujourd'hui à ce que ça
redevienne propriété québécoise avec la
famille dutil la caisse de dépôt de
fonds ftq
oui je mets pas ton dieu j'ai commencé à
travailler à cannes amant 61 au début
oui directement début on avait une usine
de 2000 m² aujourd'hui on a une usine de
5000 pieds carrés avec 800 personnes
ayant travaillé à 81 500 dollars la
saint gédéon d'art tél il ya une chose
qui est importante
il fallait que c'est ce que souhaitait
plutôt depuis fallait que mes enfants
prenez le challenge ou aussi parce que
et que ce soit ils marquent ce soit et
chaouchi les filles étaient d'accord
avec c'était fondamental puis avec quand
on donne d'excellents partenaires que ce
soit et la caisse de dépôt où on est
avec eux depuis 1984 qu'un coin devenues
publiques ont et avec quels fonds
solidarité et ma première aventure et
qu'elles font cette vérité ça commence
avec québec r ça fait qu' on ne vécut et
notez qu'on a vécu structal on a tout du
monde qu'on connaît qu'on ne les mêmes
valables qu on a le même but vous avez
si je me trompe pas soixante dix huit
ans monsieur dutil vous êtes toujours
soit 60 et 17 parfait mais quelques sont
pas bons dans ce que le 77 ans dont je
comprends que vous êtes toujours êtes
toujours très engagé et très impliqué
dans le fonctionnement de canam
oui mais pas qu'on a fait comme mon âge
l'a77 chanceux il fera encore mais
semaine à 60 heures 30 et 10 heures par
semaine
je tends santé mais il ya une chose qui
est certes un rendu à cet argent le
prochain 12 manches passante ne payez
rien de 12 mois quand même temps ça peut
dire que quel fusée coincé deux oreilles
que ça marche pas aussi vite la carec ça
fait
quand je pense à ça que c'est important
que la famille souhait soyez d'accord
plutôt depuis hier telecom marque est
impliqué dans qu'adam depuis une
vingtaine de 28 30 ans charlie dans
monaco la même chose plus tout ça fait
que je on est chanceux quand il me faut
avoir les bonnes personnes pour diriger
l'entreprise puis on a des bons
partenaires c'est quoi le sentiment qui
vous anime ce soir ben je content pour
nos gars de la beauce je compte 1 pour
le québec
puis les décisions mons prendre chez
nous puis dans l'intérêt en fin de
compte pas seulement de la dernière
pièce mais aussi pour elle bien être de
notre population plutôt tu veux pas 2500
personnes à saint gédéon 800 employés
dans une usine on a des responsabilités
sociales qu'on met 200 personnes à pied
à toronto
ils y ont des chances de se replacer 300
personnes mis à pied à saint-jude y en
ait au floc correct qui apporte de cana
mieux rien
oui monsieur dutil bonne chance pour la
suite merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous ce soir
merci